Pappy candy, which was actually
a fan. They did the Watergate,
like they sat there and went deep like
all night, but he definitely a hunter,
definitely shit on him. Oh, he
shit on him hard. That'd be cute.
Shit back on him hard. The first night
they met was at the Nixon, um, at the,
at the um,
holiday inn in um,
1968 in New Hampshire during
Nixon's come back campaign.
And Thompson walks in and Pat Kenny goes,
who's this damn guy with the damn ski
jacket walking through our Goddamn lobby
and tops. It's like, I have a press
pass, like I'm here to do this.
And so they like have this big moment.
And then later on that night
Thompson goes to a party with, um,
campaign people and with um,
uh,
[inaudible] and he brings a big
bottle of wild Turkey. And so we can,
as a young journalist at the time, he
worked at the Saint Louis Post dispatch,
I think he'd gone to the
Columbia Journalism School
is working for Nixon as his
being policy guy. He looks at Toms, he's
like, that's the fucking, the ski. Oh,
you got a bottle of what? Oh, if you
gotta follow the old crow, like no,
we'll drink that.
And so they stayed up all night and
they talked about the Vietnam War.
And Thompson talked about how it just
figures us to be in a foreign war that's
unjust and it destroys our
democratic ideals to be doing that.
And bitcoin was like containment, nuclear
war. We're trying to get out of it.
And they listened to each other till dawn,
like that first night that they met.
Now. What was your idea behind
writing this book? Like what,
what compelled you?
I think we've mistaken Thompson.
I think that we see them more
as like a Doonesbury character.
I think people who know
him really well don't.
But I think that most people through
whatever cultural forces that we've had,
well the boys,
cause a lot of people don't know
the comparison what the Doonesbury.
So I think in the eighties or
seventies, eighties, nineties, um,
that cartoon Doonesbury by
Gary Trudeau, it became, um,
there was a character
on it called Uncle Duke.
And Uncle Duke was based
on Hunter Thompson.
And he was kind of an exaggerated
version of Hunter Thompson.
He was a cartoonish version
of hunters Thompson.
And I think Terry Gilliam did a
wonderful and kind of our tourist job on,
um, like a brilliant job on
fear and loathing in Las Vegas.
But that's also an exaggerated
version of Hunter Thompson.
And we forget today the amount of work
on Hunter Thompson did the effort he put
out,
we forget that he was a
straight journalist or he did
the freelance assignments.
He wrote the straight articles for
years to make money for his family.
And it wasn't until he
had his breakthrough with
hell's angels that he could
develop the style that
we identify with today.
And so it kills me that we identify him
more as a clown or like a, you know,
more as a cartoonish figure as opposed
to a very serious political pinker,
political activist and serious writer
who can give us insight into the fucking
shit show we experience
every moment today. Well,
I think the perception
of him is fairly nuanced.
I don't think that everybody thinks
of them as a cartoon character,
although particularly
later on in this life,
he was relegated to that because he
really didn't speak well, you know,
later on in his life when he was just
the drugs taken over phone and the owl
because his son writes about the alcohol.
One writes so beautifully about the toll.
Alcoholism took on a hunter s Thompson.
We couldn't talk anymore. I mean,
when he was deep into his sixties,
his heart bars,
those are just tired of that.
It was so hard to even understand them.
There's a awful piece that he did with
Conan O'brien where Conan went to a woody
creek and shotguns,
uh,
off the back porch with them and you
could barely understand a fucking word
hunter saying.
That's why I tried to end it with Nixon
leaving because it was really sad when
Nixon resigned. A Hunter Thompson
was at the Connecticut Hilton,
which is a hotel right by the
White House. Any Liebowitz, um,
the photographer with rolling
stone was calling him and saying,
we need to get to the White House.
Nixon is a leaving.
Like he's going to get on the helicopter
and Thompson just laid in the grass and
he didn't go, you know,
and that was heartbreaking.
And he didn't end up writing the
eight page spread that he needed to.
Instead it became any Liebowitz is
photography, which was a famous and um,
in retrospect,
like huge move for her career.
But I think that that pain right there
of thinking that he'd spent 10 years,
I mean, he hated Nixon since
the checkers speech, you know,
and Nixon was the VP for Eisenhower.
He hated Nixon since 1962 when
Nixon lost the, um, California, um,
uh, uh, governor I'm ship
and said, you and the press,
you been giving me the shaft for so long,
like you won't have Dick
Nixon to kick around anymore.
Like Thompson had seen that
Nixon was somebody who said,
I'm just the poor son of a butcher. I'm
just this like very hardworking, you know,
American that represents all
of us were be hind that like,
he was a politically, um, you know,
ravenous monster who was anticommunist,
who would go to any extent to win.
And Thompson saw that. And Thompson knew
that other people saw it. And in 1964,
the Barry Goldwater
convention in San Francisco,
my favorite lead named arena of
all time, the cow palace, um,
Barry Goldwater was going to
speak to accept the nomination.
And what happened was,
and Nixon was introducing them,
it was Nixon's way back
from the wilderness.
Thompson was a few rows back cause the
first time Thompson I think was that
close to see him live. And it makes, it's
like, you know, poor son of a butcher,
don't think about me, just think about
Barry Goldwater, Mr Conservative,
he'll become Mr president.
And Thompson was like,
fuck everybody here knows he's lying.
But they think that that act of lying
is a skill and the way they used car
salesman who lies but can make a lot
of money off it, right. Skillful,
the way that Trump by selling steaks to
people and then they go bankrupt and he
gets rich.
That's an American skill and Thompson
sense that from the start with Nixon.
And so I think he battled against
Nixon for a decade, for a lot of years.
And when Nixon left,
I think he felt spent.
And so I try not to focus on the later
I ended then in [inaudible] 74 because I
think it's, he wrote some beautiful things
afterwards. He was still a gratefully,
you definitely had some moments where
he decided to not do the assignment that
he was supposed to do.
And it was kind of sad.
Like I'm the Ali foreman fight,
fucking floated in the pool,
float in the pool with a Nixon mask on,
flew all the way to Africa and ms
one of the greatest sports moments.
It was like game six of
'em, you know, um, you know,
the Boston red sox versus the reds or
think Ali was something different to
people than I think it's,
I
don't think we have
someone like that today.
So it's very difficult for
us to understand if people
today look at Ali and they
go, oh, he was a heavyweight boxing
champion. He was way more than that.
He was,
uh,
a cultural figure that represented
the resistance to the Vietnam War and
represented it with the biggest loss
that any public figure it ever shown.
And willingly gave up three years of his
career in his prime from age 27 to 30,
from 1967 from the Cleveland
Big Cat Williams fight.
He didn't fight again for three years.
He didn't train,
he didn't do anything. They
kept him from his career. Why?
When he was in his prime, when he
was the best heavyweight of all time.
And he spoke publicly and often and
in we was fucking hated all over the
country, but he represented
something different. Like, uh,
my parents were hippies and
when I was a little kid,
he lost to Leon Spinks and
the rematch was on television.
My parents never watched TV and they
definitely never watched boxing and they,
they, they sat in front of that TV
to watch that. I remember thinking,
I can't believe my parents want to watch
a boxing match. Like this is crazy.
And I was probably like,
I don't know,
maybe eight or nine years
old or something at the time.
And I just remember thinking,
I can't believe my parents want to watch
a boxing match. And that's what really,
when it sunk into me at a really early
age that this guy was not just this
heavyweight boxer. He was,
he was, uh, a cultural icon.
He was a historical figure.
He meant he meant a lot into hunter.
He met a lot.
He meant something,
something much bigger
than just just a boxer.
And so hunter thought he was
going to a death sentence.
George Foreman had crushed Joe
Frazier. He crushed everybody. I mean,
he was so powerful. George Foreman
to this day is one of the all time,
scariest heavyweights of all
time with without a doubt. He,
he could hit so fucking hard and
literally pick guys off their feet.
He hit Joe Frazier and lifted him
off his feet with a punch. And uh,
everybody was convinced that
that was going to happen to Ali,
that Ali had been past its prime.
And look,
just look at what George
Foreman had done to Joe Frazier.
What is he going to do to Muhammad Ali
and Ali just rope a dope them until he
got tired and then fucked him
up in front of the whole world.
That's one of the greatest
athletic moments. I mean we forget that
athletes, athletes like curt flood,
you know, they've, they risked who's that?
Curt flood was the American baseball
player who challenged the reserve clause
cause it makes, while you weren't allowed
to, um, get free agency for another team.
And curt flood was this
great player and he was like,
I'm going to sit out and I'm going to
wait. Athletes like Colin Kaepernick,
they've sacrificed her career.
It's not the same with Muhammad Ali who
was like Babe Ruth and Barry bonds and
like everybody combined at that one
moment. Right? But he was risking,
it's the opposite of Trump.
Trump used his celebrity to become this
even more mangled version of himself and
get more power while he used his celebrity
to speak for his virtue in his value
and his beliefs and set like Thomson
was really good at understanding what
people sacrifice when people have
to give up the wager. You know,
between what that act will be, what
the results will be. They may be later.
But he knew that.
And so his respect for Ali for
giving up those years of his prime,
you know, was, was enduring.
He Keep Thompson came back from that
fight and he gave his son on one a boxing
gloves, um, that, um, or, or,
uh, at least boxing gloves. Wow.
Yeah.
It's a very,
very unfortunate that he missed that fi
because it would have been fascinating
to hear his take on it.
To me.
I'm sure he would've been so moved
when he saw all the win, but it was in,
I mean that's a good point.
It was indicative of,
I think the stress and the pressure that
the last decade of covering Nixon had
taken out on him. Well, there's a
little bit of that, but let's be honest,
he was also kind of a fuck up.
I mean,
when he was writing for rolling stone
and they gave him that, that early facts.
Oh yeah. And he would fuck that thing up.
He would unplug it and plug it back in.
He would do it. Just so he could go to
the bar and say, this thing doesn't work.
But that was the end. I think of
his arc where he was still on point.
He was still playing the role of a
serious journalist and he would use that
persona as a fuckup and there's
letters by yawn winter being like,
you cannot turn in your articles
three hours before we go to press.
I know you made it.
This doesn't fucking work.
And so he was beginning to break down.
Then he was also,
I think on the tail end of his decade
of being a journalist who had met every
deadline so that he could fucking feed
his family and he could afford how farm
like there were.
There's moments where before he got the
contract for Hell's angels in 1965 he
was ready to be like a longshoreman.
He was going and looking for work in
the mornings in San Francisco, you know,
to try to support his family.
He was willing to give up writing and
instead that article blew up and he,
all these beautiful letters
began to arrive at three
19 Parnassus where he lived
at, um, at the top of the Haight
Ashbury and I'm San Francisco.
And that opened up his chance
to continue being a writer,
but money was the main motivating factor.
And so I think once money like unfurled,
once alcoholism I think took its toll
and once he couldn't walk around anymore
addict political camp convention without
people just like grabbing his shoulder
and saying, you're a hunter
Thompson, does that happen?
I think things began to change.
Yeah.
That's one of the things that he
talked about that I thought was really
interesting that he became
a part of the story.
It wasn't just that he was covering
stories, he couldn't be anonymous anymore.
He was in many cases more famous than
the people that he was covering. Yeah.
You know, like when he would go
to meet Nixon, all Nick Nixon,
secret service agents wanted to meet
him and they wanted to get an autograph
from him and shake his hand and it
was just too weird. Everything I got.
And then there's the
alcoholism, alcoholism. Look it,
it's a depressant. It wrecks you.
And if you read, you know, we,
me and Greg Fitzsimmons on
a podcast once read off, uh,
that one journalist who had a
detailed hunters daily routine.
And so we, we read the routine
and they put a techno beat to it.
It's fucking hilarious. That was
a bad, that's a set. Those are so,
it's so funny because those
seem funny now, but they're,
they're kind of a death nail.
Like, I mean that, that daily
routine, um, that was, um,
the, the biography hunter, it was in that
and it's just, it's heartbreaking. I mean,
we've got to remember that the dedication
to fear and loathing in Las Vegas was
he who makes a beast of
himself gets rid of pain man.
And I think the world was
painful for a Hunter Thompson.
It was people to see powerful
people abused the week, you know,
and like take what they wanted brazenly
without being held accountable.
I think it was hard to deal with shitty
editors who cut half your fucking essay
on Nixon or half your story.
It made it into something that had
nothing to do with the effort that you put
out. Yeah. I think it was hard
to pay your bills and you know,
live the way that you wanted to live.
And I think a lot of that gets undermined.
I just want people to realize
how much effort he put out,
especially during those years
where he was like, all right,
I want to be a great journalist.
I want to have a voice in our society.
I want to participate in
our national conversation.
My only path towards that is to work
harder than everybody else to be at places
when things happen, when they matter.
And he's sacrificed a lot for that.
But he was there and he's a voice in a
light that we can have in this moment. Um,
which is another troubling
moment in American history.